Bí thư chú thích nước to lâm cộng phu nhân đi tầu cao tốc tối tham và làm việc tại thành phố Nam Ninh vào sáng
mùi sáng tưởng tư trong khun cộng chuyến tham cấp nhận lức tử Trung Quốc.
Nam Ninh thuộc quốc tự trị dân tập truang quảng đây các mắt kinh khoảng 20-40km sát.
Tầu cao tốc trên bệnh này trẻ khoảng 30-50km trên dờ.
Chên tầu tộc bií thư chú thích nước to lâm bây tạo ấn tượng về quả trị phát triển mạnh lưỡi đường xác cao tốc của Trung Quốc.
Lãnh đạo Việt Nam mong buồn 2 nước thức tục tăng cường hợp tác kết đối rau thông bao gồm đường xác.
Bí sự phát triển xanh tăng trường quốc gia tông thời đe nghị lãnh đạo ngành đường xác
và các suy nhiệm chú Quốc chết sẽ kinh nghiệm và hỗ trợ.
Tham gia cùng Việt Nam trong quả trịng xây dự chuyển xác công nghệ cho các sự án đường xác quan trọng tại Việt Nam.
Tính đến đều năm 2019, hẹn thấm đường xác đăng bệnh của chú Quốc đã tổ chưa dài 1 chăm sóm mi lâm nghiệm kí lộn mẹt.
Chúng đỏ đường xác cao tốc khoảng 50.000 kí lộn mẹt, giận đầu thế giới và chiếm hơn bệnh mươi phần trăm tổ chưa dài đường xác cao tốc tăng cầu.
Chuyến tham cấp nhận nước tới Trung Quốc của tổ biệt thư chú tích nước tổ lâm,
cộng đăng lĩnh đạo Việt Nam kéo dài từ vệ bốn đến mùi bài tháng tư, với các khoảng đậu khảo sát,
tìm hiểu mua ín tí điểm khu đô thị mới, hẹn thống hạn tăng và công nghiệm đường xác,
cơ sản nghiên cứu ứng dục giữ đệ nhân tạo đổi mời sáng tạo tại mắc kinh, hả mắc và quảng tầy?